[Musique]
guirlandes foot mégaphone ou encore
corne de supporters dans cette boutique
spécialisée dans la vente d'articles de
fête le gérant a décoré sa vitrine aux
couleurs du football club des vertèbres
une famille de sportifs mes enfants
jouent au fc versailles - bijoux
en étant jeune donc avoir une équipe
dans les yvelines car ça de la coupe de
france c'est génial qua non pour nous
c'est logique de les supporter nous
parle de versailles en positif on montre
qu'il ya aussi du sport à versailles
donc c'est génial quoi un soutien
légitime pour une journée spéciale
quelques clients sont également au
rendez vous et beaucoup sont curieux de
cette vitrine bien remplie beaucoup de
gens s'arrêtent on a des gens qui sont
venus acheter des produits faits me gêne
un peu de supporteurs on sent que bahia
quand même si l'engouement au niveau de
la ville qui est aussi sportif du groupe
pour l'occasion une fan zone est
installé ce soir place du marché notre
dame de quoi profiter de tous les
équipements du parfait supporter
[Musique]